hey guys real quick before i get into
the video i wanted to announce the five
winners from my giveaway of digital
copies of skyward sword hd
their names will be present on the
screen in three
two one
tada congratulations you guys i'll be
hitting your dms up
on twitter later on today so please stay
tuned for a message from me
and now on to the video three words guys
skyward sword
hd well i guess four if you say high
definition let me just say real quick
that i have never
been more happy to be wrong seriously
last year i made the mistake of
attempting to predict that skyward sword
would never be ported to the switch for
some technical jargon reasons but
lo and behold nintendo just slapped my
logic out the window and down the street
because
boom july 16th skyward sword hd will be
coming to a nintendo switch
near you now some of you out there have
had the pleasure of playing this gem of
a game before on the wii
and the infamous motion control debate
aside i think most players would agree
that it was a pretty good zelda game all
things considered but the sales numbers
tell us that the vast majority of fans
of the legend of zelda franchise
actually did not end up buying and
playing the game and that's even more
true today than
ever since breath of the wild has
single-handedly helped to expand the
zelda fan base
multiple times over however that means
that there's a really good chance that
you watching and listening to my voice
right now may be one of the people who
haven't played the game before
in that case this video is for you of
course everyone is still invited to stay
and watch
but what i mean by that is in this video
i'm going to go over some very
very key points of breath of the wild
that were actually either heavily
inspired or straight up
copied from skyward sword that you may
or may not have known about in the first
place we have the one and only hylia the
goddess
statue princess zelda by the way if that
last bit shocked you just now you should
totally check out my previous theory on
the goddess statues anyway
hylia as a goddess being or even just an
idea was not present in zelda lore until
the release of skyward sword
not even kidding for such an immensely
important member of zelda lore it's
interesting to think about the fact that
we've only known of her existence
since skyward sword so for only the past
10 years
even though breath of the wild is the
game that takes place the furthest from
skyward sword in the timeline
to us the players it was the game that
was released right after
and lo and behold the goddess hylia is
not only present in the game but
is literally everywhere you can't go to
any town in the game without seeing the
physical representation of skyward
sword's direct
inspiration and what's more is the
goddess statues and shrines are even
constructed exactly like they were in
skyward sword in fact the entire setting
for breath of the wild is extremely
similar to skyward swords because
as we know skyward sword tells the story
of the beginning of the franchise and if
you'll recall one of the first things
you hear in breath of the wild is that
the great plateau
is the birthplace of all of hyrule but
i'm getting carried away with this at
this point if you'd like a more in-depth
look at the comparison between the
related areas of the two games i
recommend this video by rmfh
and hey tell him i sent you secondly the
talking master sword was also taken
directly from skyward sword you see
the master sword has for a long time
been theorized as having some sort of
sentience to it as in twilight princess
for instance midna states that the sword
chose link as its master instead of link
choosing the sword
interesting choice of words that for a
long time was unresolved and left up to
speculations
until skyward sword that is if you
haven't played it you might not have
heard of the individual in the game
whose name i still cannot get a straight
answer on how it's pronounced
wow i can literally hear you typing out
her pronunciation in the comments below
huh you guys are funny phi or fee as
some call her
is revealed in skyward sword to be the
sentience in the goddess sword which
later on becomes the one and only master
sword well unless there's actually two
of them but
anyway she serves as link's companion
throughout his adventure and lets him
know
every time the batteries in his wiimote
are running low yeah anyway the point is
that phi
is a being that lives inside of the
master sword and for all intents and
purposes
actually is the master sword in breath
of the wild we see the master sword
speaking to zelda while this is already
enough to point towards a skyward sword
inspiration
the developers took it one step further
and actually put the same
little musical tone in the game that
plays whenever fee speaks to you in
skyward sword
take a
the listen so he can't
yup there you have it the second
straight up 100
bonafide skyward swordism thirdly and
most obviously
parkour and stamina but let's face it
mostly parkour
you see one of the most ground-breaking
things about breath of the wild that
separates it from other open world games
is the fact that
link here can literally climb anything
except for smooth surfaces apparently
but for some reason i find that one
difficult to explain since while he
can't climb the surfaces of sheikah
shrines he can instead climb the
completely smooth walls of gerudo town
either way link's parkour initiatives
originated in skyward sword where he
could sprint at a wall and take a solid
two steps directly upwards like this was
legend of assassin's skyward creed
this was the first time in any zelda
game where you were able to even
slightly parkour much less sprint as
link and the longer you sprinted or did
anything requiring physical exertion the
more stamina you used and thus
nintendo invented the wheel the stamina
wheel
look familiar because it basically
functions the exact same way in breath
of the wild
you sprint or climb or even hit hard and
you spend stamina
now one thing that breath of the wild
improved upon was the fact that you
could actually level up your stamina
wheel by way of the spirit orbs gained
from shrines either way though it's
interesting to think back upon the fact
that we can
literally see the roots of this very key
and well-known in-game mechanic
fourthly crafting now this is an in-game
mechanic that's super popular in the
open world genre already
but in terms of breath of the wild it
was completely absent from zelda games
until skyward sword
in the game crafting was used to upgrade
your equipment and gear at the gear shop
in the bazaar and even craft things like
potions at the potion shop
in breath of the wild this concept
evolved into three things
cooking the great fairies and the
sheikah scientist duo
cooking of course covers the creation of
potions and elixirs like the previous
game but also
most obviously had the added ability to
create you know
cooked food the great fairies replaced
the old bizarre upgrades by allowing you
to gather materials and enhance the
armor you wear
and pura slash robbie will either
upgrade your runes which replace
tools or craft gear from the sheikh
materials one thing that breath of the
wild did not change from skyward swords
crafting is the fact that link can't
just
up and craft something by himself
similar to the shopkeepers in the bazaar
link still needs to go visit the sheikah
duo the great fairies or a pod over an
open flame to craft whatever his
hearts desire fifthly and most
importantly the sail cloth i mean
paraglider
the paracloth was a concept taken
directly from skyward sword since one of
the main aspects of the game is quite
literally falling from the sky it's a
pretty decent death preventing measure
to take when doing such an action mr
onuma specifically mentioned this in the
previous nintendo direct when he was
talking about breath of the wild skyward
sword inspirations as well
they did improve the sail glider's
functionality by allowing link to glide
with it instead of just
fall slowly but the fact remains that
the concept of gliding to reach areas
previously unreachable 100 came from
skyward sword and that's the list anyway
guys thank you so much for watching and
i hope that if you haven't played the
game before or in a while
you found this interesting let me know
if you learned something new or if i
forgot something in the comments below
please be sure to leave a like if you
enjoyed the video so that this gets
spread around to others and helps hype
up skyward sword's release
also subscribe if you haven't already
for much more nintendo content to come
as always huge huge huge thanks to my
amazing supporters who are literally the
people that make all of this possible
please give a huge welcome to a new
bandit level supporter of mine the skull
kid nico
and the two new faces of x superfish and
not so heroic link who have all decided
to join my elite bandit crew
thank you guys so much and if you
watching are interested in joining said
crew and helping the next videos come to
life
please feel free to check out that join
button located below or find the link to
my patreon in the description below
also down there is a link to my merch
website where i've just gone live with
some truly snazzy new
bandit coin or boin related merch
even if you can't support monthly you
can still join the bandit crew by
picking up just one of these cute little
merch items
and trust me it is so incredibly
appreciated that's all i've got for you
in this one so as always i hope you have
a wonderful rest of your day
this is masentana bandit signing out
[Music]
you